Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Heute wieder mal mit Eindrücken aus Evian. Und zwar begrüße ich bei mir Marcus Bark, der unter anderem für sportsau.de dort vor Ort ist. Markus, wie toll, dass du wieder Zeit für mich gefunden hast, obwohl ihr vor Ort ja doch einen stressigen Job habt. Also wir nehmen Montag Abend auf für alle Hörer, die das jetzt vielleicht erst am Dienstag hören werden. Lass uns doch mal, ich möchte über eine Reihe von Themen mit dir sprechen, aber lass uns mal mit der Nationalmannschaft beginnen, wie einfallsreich ich weiß und auch mit der PK, die Joachim Löw heute gegeben hat. Ich habe nur Ausschnitte davon sehen können, aber muss sagen, ich habe ihn sehr locker erlebt, auch sehr entschlossen, hatte so ein bisschen den Eindruck, für den geht es jetzt gerade weil die Rückfläge dann doch gar nicht so weich sind mit den vielen Verletzten und einem gesperrten Schlüsselspieler, dass es für ihn jetzt erst so richtig losgeht. Er fühlt sich herausgefordert.
Das denke ich auch. Der Eindruck, dass er sehr locker ist, den hat man eigentlich schon seit vielen Monaten. Nach dem WM-Titel hat er, glaube ich, so eine Entwicklung eingesetzt, dass er viel entspannter ist, was natürlich auch dazu beiträgt. Und er hat ja heute auch gesagt, ich liebe solche Spiele, ist, dass er inzwischen nicht dauernd hören muss, er hat noch gegen keine große Nation gewonnen. Das war einfach ein großes Thema und jetzt sieht das ja ganz anders aus. Und nach einem Sieg, selbst wenn das statistisch anders zählt, gegen Italien, kann man sich sicherlich auch auf Frankreich freuen. Und ich fand auch eine Stelle bei der PK heute bemerkenswert, als er sich freute, dass jetzt hier auch in Frankreich mal eine Euphorie losgebrochen ist. Gestern war das tatsächlich selbst hier in Evian bemerkenswert, dass er in derselben Situation ist und die Mannschaft wie in 2014 in Brasilien als auch eine ganze Nation darauf wartete, dass der Gastgeber Deutschland rauswirft. Und das Ergebnis von Brasilien ist auf jeden Fall bekannt. Und ich denke, dass er sich wieder, wie schon gegen Italien, auch sehr gute Chancen ausrechnet, selbst wenn jetzt ein paar Spieler ersetzt werden müssen.
Ich habe auch tatsächlich den Eindruck, das sagt sich natürlich leicht aus meiner Entfernenperspektive, aber dass Löw eigentlich wenig zu verlieren hat. Denn selbst wenn man jetzt ausschiede gegen Frankreich, dann ist ein Teilargument immer, mein Gott, Mats Hummels hat wirklich gefehlt. Und wo wären wir wohl hingekommen, wenn Mario Gomez sich nicht verletzt hätte? Und dann ist ja noch nicht mal klar, wie es mit Semikidira und Bastian Schweinsteiger aussehen wird. Das heißt, es wird immer auch ein Argument geben, wenn man sich nicht komplett rausschießen lässt, wenn es jetzt nicht ein 7 zu 1 gegen Deutschland wird. Dann kann man immer mit erhobenem Haupt gehen, sage ich mal.
Würde ich nicht ganz so sehen, weil es bleibt ja immer noch die Hintertür. Es ist ja klar, das haben wir auch Samstag gesehen. Es wird über den Trainer und die Taktik und die Aufstellung so viel diskutiert, dass wenn er jemanden jetzt aufstellt und er muss ja neue Leute bringen oder andere Leute bringen, wahrscheinlich wird ja auch ein Debitant dabei sein. Wenn das dann in die Hose geht, dann ist ja klar, dass er auch wieder kritisiert wird. Aber von der Richtung her stimmt es schon.
Wie groß hältst du denn die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass er keinen Debitanten bringt? Er könnte ja auch Hovedis aufrecht stellen und Kimmich auf die Sechs ziehen zum Beispiel. Mustavi hat ja schon ein Spiel gemacht.
Das hat er in der PK heute ausgeschlossen, Kimmich auf die Sechs. Man muss nicht immer alles so genau, wie er es sagt, glauben. Aber da war er so klar, das wird er nicht machen. Er hat ja auch vor dem Italien-Spiel beispielsweise im ZDF gesagt, das wird nicht die gleiche Elfie gegen die Slowakei spielen. Das hätte auch ein Ablenkungsmanöver sein können, stimmte aber halt auch. Und Kimmich, ich glaube, das stimmt. Er wird nicht ins Zentrum ziehen. Und es bleibt dann, finde ich, noch eine andere Möglichkeit, dass es Özil zurückziehen, macht er aber, ja genau, in dem Testspiel, das macht er aber, ich glaube nicht, dass es, also ich glaube schon, dass die Entscheidung zwischen Weigl und Enric Czarn fallen wird. Eins vielleicht noch, weil du auch sagtest, du hättest nicht die gesamte PK gesehen. Und Kedira fällt also fürs Halbfinale definitiv aus. Das kann sein, oder er hat gesagt, wir versuchen alles fürs Finale, fürs Halbfinale besteht keine Chance. Bei Schweinsteiger sieht das anders aus. Aber so zwischen den Zeilen, auch bei dem Satz, ich habe einmal den Fehler gemacht, einen Spieler beim wichtigen Spiel im Turnier einzusetzen. Das will ich nicht wiederholen. Das mache ich nur, wenn einer 100 Prozent belastbar ist. Deshalb glaube ich eher nicht, weil Schweinsteiger hat unglaublich wenig gespielt dieses Jahr. Ich habe noch mal geguckt, in den Minuten, in denen er gespielt hat, hat er 12,7 Kilometer gelaufen. Das ist eine ganze Menge. Das laufen sehr, sehr viele Spieler nicht während 90 Minuten. Der hat jetzt ein bisschen mehr, aber dann auch noch angeschlagen. Und dann gegen Frankreich mit ziemlich dynamischen Mittelfeldspielern. Ich glaube eher, dass Löw jemanden bringt, der 100% fit ist. Und soweit man das mitbekommen hat. Ich wüsste nicht, dass die irgendwann mal eine Trainingseinheit ausgesetzt haben. Sind Weichel und Scharen absolut fit.
Ich fand es ja interessant, dass das wohl die erste Aktion von Sebastian Schweinsteiger nach seiner Einwechslung war, in der er sich gleich seine Verletzung zugezogen hat. Da sieht man mal, wie die mit Adrenalin vollgepusht ist, dann doch noch irgendwie übers Spiel tragen können.
Du, ich muss dir ganz ehrlich sagen, ich habe die Szene beobachtet. Und Schweinsteiger stand dann da, hat sich ans rechte Knie gefasst und dann diese typischen Bewegungen gemacht, die man so, wenn man einen Schlag gekriegt hat, macht, mal testen, wie das aussieht, wie es geht. Und da waren so 20 Sekunden, wo ich dachte, ups, jetzt muss er schon nach einer Viertelstunde ein zweites Mal wechseln. Weil es war halt auch wieder das rechte Knie, an das er sich dann gefasst hat. Und dann hatte man so noch eine Minute den Eindruck, er läuft nicht rund, aber dann ging es halt doch wieder. Das war wohl im ersten Moment der Schmerz des Schlages, den er da gespürt hat. Aber ich dachte erst, oh, das sieht so aus, als wäre jetzt eine Viertelstunde vorbei und zwar wechselt schon dahinten. Das wäre natürlich, wenn man auch sieht, wie das Spiel dann weiterging, ziemlich bitter gewesen. Und ich fand auch, dass Schweinsteiger unter den Umständen sehr, sehr ordentliche Partie gespielt hat. Das war schon in Ordnung.
Ich habe mich dann zum ersten Mal wieder an diese Szene zurückerinnert, tatsächlich nach seinem verschossenen Elfmeter, als er sich dann quasi direkt neben dem Elfmeterpunkt erst mal mit den Fingerspitzen bis an die Fußsohlen gestreckt hat. Wo ich mir dachte, in einem Moment so großer Enttäuschung würde man, glaube ich, eher versuchen, irgendwie da einfach wegzulaufen langsam. Da dachte ich mir, das sieht irgendwie auch nach Schmerzen aus. Warum dehnt er sich jetzt quasi aus, mit dem Elfmeterpunkt? Da habe ich mir dann kurz gedacht, lief der nicht unrund und hat sich ja leider bestätigt. Jetzt so in der Rotretrospective oder der halben Retrospective, wir sind ja noch im Turnier, findest du, dass sich Löws Nominierungstaktik mit einem Backup pro taktischer Position so grob gesprochen bewährt hat? Also dass er jetzt eben aus Czarn und Weigl wählen kann? Oder würdest du sagen, hätte er das mal lieber beim Mittelstürmer gemacht?
Ich denke schon, dass sich das bewährt hat, weil beim Mittelstürmer hat er ja immer noch mehrere Optionen. Götze kann das spielen, Müller kann das spielen. Zur Not, glaube ich, könnte das auch Hösel spielen. Also der hat es in der Nationalmannschaft, als das letztmals versucht wurde, hat das nicht gut gemacht. Das war aber auch ein Testspiel. Bei der U21 EM, die die gewonnen haben, kann ich mich erinnern, dass er das auch einige Spiele gespielt hat. Das wäre natürlich auch noch mal ein Überraschungsmoment. Ich glaube nicht, dass es passieren wird. Aber die Möglichkeit ist auch da. Draxler ist auch ab und an jetzt in die Zentralespitze gegangen. Ich schütze auch nicht unbedingt seine Position, aber Löw ist halt jemand, der sagt sich, bevor ich jemanden in den Kader nominiere, von dem ich nicht 100 Prozent überzeugt bin, dann lasse ich ihn halt weg, auch wenn er die Position spielen kann, auf der wir etwas knapper besetzt sind. Jetzt ist ihn natürlich Reus auch weggegangen. Das ist einer, der auch die Position hätte spielen können.
Vielleicht gibt es auch tatsächlich zu Gomez nicht den 1 zu 1-Ersatz, den es zu anderen Spielern gab. Wenn man jetzt sieht, auf rechts hat er sich letztlich entschieden zwischen Rudi und Kimmich und erstaunlicherweise für viele Beobachter Rudi nach Hause geschickt, der vorher immer mit dabei war. Aber das hat sich bewährt. Bei Weigl konnte man es jetzt noch nicht im Turnier sehen, aber man hat es in der Bundesligasaison gesehen, dass er auch in seiner Debitanten-Saison in der 1. Liga wahnsinnig passig, anspielstark war und einfach sehr, sehr schlau gespielt hat und deswegen auch so viele Ballkontakte hatte. Also hat schon anscheinend an den Stellen, wo er auch ernsthafte Backup-Möglichkeiten hatte, die Entscheidung sich nicht leicht gemacht und bisher ist er damit ganz gut gefahren. Was würdest du sagen, wie ist so die Stimmung in der Mannschaft auch? Kriegt man dafür ein Gefühl, wenn man vor Ort ist oder ist es schwierig, weil man immer nur die reingewaschenen PK-Zitate bekommt?
Das ist natürlich schwierig, weil man nie so eng dabei ist, dass man das hundertprozentig beurteilen kann. Aber das, was man so auch im Gespräch mit Leuten vom DFB hört, ist das alles in Butter. Auch Spieler, die früher mal ein bisschen isoliert waren. Aber das ist ja auch ein offenes Geheimnis, dass Mats Hummels mal mit einigen Kollegen ein bisschen Theater hatte. Das soll sich sehr geändert haben. Ich hatte letztens kurz die Gelegenheit, mit dem Mats Hummels zu sprechen. Der macht also auch einen äußerst entspannten Eindruck. Das hängt immer damit zusammen, wie die Ergebnisse sind, wie man selber in Form ist. Ich finde Boateng, Hummels, auch wenn ich die anderen spiele, nicht alle über 90 Minuten und auch wenn, dann nicht immer so ganz konzentriert gesehen habe. Aber ich glaube, das ist mit Abstand das beste Innenverteidigerpaar bei dieser Europameisterschaft.
Ja, würde ich auch. Aus meiner subjektiven Warte würde ich das auch bestätigen. Ich glaube, da klatscht man sich an derselben Straße in die Hände und freut sich auf die nächste Saison. Aber man muss vielleicht auch erst mal gucken, in welchem Zustand man die Spieler zurückbekommt. Ich würde gerne mit dir noch über ein paar allgemeine Themen sprechen, die nicht mehr so richtig stattgefunden haben in der Berichterstattung. Und wenn ich jetzt schon mal die Chance habe, mit jemandem vor Ort zu sprechen, würde ich das gerne abklopfen, ob es da auch einfach nichts berichten wertes gab. Zum einen haben wir vor dem Turnier und in der ersten Woche sehr stark thematisiert den Aspekt der Terrorgefahr und der Sicherheitskontrollen vor Ort, wie die Franzosen das angehen, dann ja auch in Zusammenhang mit Hooligan-Ausschreitungen, vor allem bei England gegen Russland, aber auch bei Deutschland gegen Ukraine. Wie ist denn dieses ganze Sicherheitsthema? Ist das noch ein Thema vor Ort? Hat sich da vielleicht auch in Frankreich was gewandelt?
Also als Thema nimmt man das eigentlich gar nicht mehr so wahr. Da ich jetzt gar nicht in Französisch spreche, verfolge ich halt auch die französischen Zeitungen nicht so. Aber wenn ich auch mal durch die Programme seppe, und es gibt, glaube ich, drei oder zwei, die mindestens acht Stunden über Fußball reden hier in Frankreich, und da wird über Sicherheit eigentlich gar nicht mehr geredet. Es gibt weiterhin die starken Sicherheitskontrollen. Also wir müssen noch jedes Mal, wenn wir in unser Containerdorf kommen, auch wenn die Leute uns jetzt gut kennen und wir schon miteinander quatschen, wie es geht und so weiter, müssen wir immer noch unsere Tasche öffnen, alles zeigen. Wenn wir mit dem Auto hochfahren, wird das im Kofferraum geguckt und durch eine Sicherheitsschleuse geht das auch jedes Mal. Das ist an den Stadien auch absolut üblich. Ich weiß nicht, ob die Präsenz der Polizei abgenommen hat. Ich kann mir das nicht vorstellen. In Bordeaux war es sehr merkwürdig. Da bin ich in der Stadt gewesen. Es war samstags Mittags sehr belebt, ein normales Einkaufspublikum, das durch die Straße ging. Da hat man gar keine Polizei gesehen. Dann bin ich zurück zu unserem Hotel, um mich auf den Weg zum Stadion zu machen. Da kamen mir zehn bewaffnete Soldaten an. Aber da waren überhaupt keine Menschen, weil das schon abseits der Stadt war. Die sind da nur so patrouilliert, wo die Menschen waren. Da hat man gar nichts von mitgekriegt. Aber man hat ja auch gehört, dass ziemlich viele Leute, ziemlich viele Sicherheitskräfte in Zivil unterwegs sind. Aber das Thema ist klar, da brauchen wir nicht drum herum reden. Bis etwas passiert, wird das kein Thema mehr werden, denke ich.
Ich hoffe auch, dass es kein Thema mehr wird. Mich hat es eben nur interessiert, ob sich da auch vor Ort etwas verändert hat. Es ist ja schön, dass es kein Thema mehr ist.
Also es gibt, wie überall, es gibt Ordner, die gucken genau rein. Also ich wundere mich manchmal, ich habe eine Tasche, da sind drei Reißverschlüsse. Bei den meisten muss ich einen aufmachen und wenn die dann einen Computer sehen, dann sagen die alles klar. In den anderen beiden Fächern könnte ich dann was weiß ich was mitnehmen. Aber es gibt auch manche an Stadien, die lassen sich haarklein alles zeigen und Sonnenbrillen-Ethoien muss man da auch aufmachen. Das kostet dann natürlich Zeit und manchmal sind die Schlangen wirklich lang, weil es nur eine Schleuse gibt und es sind ja unglaublich viele Journalisten und auch Techniker und Stewards und was weiß ich auch. Die Sicherheitsleute selber werden ja nochmal kontrolliert, wenn sie in ein Stadium gehen. Da kann schon mal eine Stunde vorbei ziehen, bis man dann im Stadion ist.
Und hat dafür die Mehrheit Verständnis?
Ja, absolut. Also ich kann mich nur an eine Situation erinnern, das war wirklich ein bisschen blöd, weil es da einen Platzregen gegeben hat nach dem Training. Und das war so, als alle schon 20 Mal da durchgegangen sind, weil das Zelt ist viel zu klein, als dass alle da reinpassen und wenn man dann da im Regen steht und hat um 11 Uhr noch einen ganzen Arbeitstag vor sich und merkt jetzt gerade, wie man komplett nass wird, dass man dann jemand sagt, Leute, lasst uns doch jetzt bitte mal so durch, es regnet wie Sau, aber das ist das einzige, woran ich mich erinnern kann. Ansonsten ist das inzwischen, das ist ja auch im Bundesliga-Stadion inzwischen üblich, von daher hat da auch jeder Verständnis für.
Warst du damals auch vor Ort beim Testspiel im November, Deutschland gegen Frankreich?
Also ich könnte eine Geschichte dazu erzählen, warum es zufälligerweise nicht der Fall war, aber um es kurz zu machen, es war tatsächlich totaler Zufall. Ich hatte die Karte zu Hause. Ich hatte jetzt noch nichts gebucht, weil das von Dortmund ausfährt. Man meint, es ist ja in ein paar Stunden nach Paris. Das wollte ich kurzfristig machen. Es hatte sich aber durch eine private Sache so ergeben, dass ich dann halt darauf verzichtet habe und habe Paris selber nicht erlebt, habe dann Hannover miterlebt. Ich habe aber hier, vielleicht haben es ja einige gesehen, mit dem Bernd Schmelzer, der damals im November auch da war, fürs Fernsehen gesprochen. Als wir dann im Stadion waren und wir darüber gesprochen haben, habe ich schon bei ihm gemerkt, dass das nochmal was mit ihm verändert hat. Ich habe es ja auch beim ersten Mal erzählt, dieses komische Geräusch und so, da war ihm schon nicht ganz so mulmig, zumal die gleichen Räume, in denen die damals untergebracht war, also das Büro, wo die ARD dann und auch das ZDF seine am Ü-Wagen steht, das war alles gleich, gleiche Umgebung und so. Von daher kann ich voll verstehen, dass sie schon da erst mal ein mulmiges Gefühl hatten. Das war sicherlich keine angenehme Nacht.
Also es ging sogar mir, ehrlich gesagt, am Bildschirm so. Ich habe das damals ja auch nur als TV-Zuschauer erlebt. Aber ich fand es auch schon irgendwie komisch, allein die Absparungen wiederzusehen vom Stadion, die man dann irgendwann halt einfach so gut vor Augen hatte, weil man den Tathergang geschildert bekam und immer Karten eingeblendet wurden. Ja, merkwürdige Situation. Aber klopfen wir mal auf alles Holz, was wir verfügbar haben. Dass wir das jetzt auch nie wieder thematisieren müssen im Rasenfunk. Mich hat es nur interessiert, weil man darüber so wenig gesprochen hat.
In den letzten Tagen habe ich mich auch mal gefragt, ob das... Aber gut, das ist halt so. Man bringt ein Thema nicht auf, wenn es keines ist, wenn es keinen aktuellen Anlass gibt. Vielleicht eine Sache noch, weil da gab es ja irgendwie auch in der Vorberichterstattung viele, die gesagt haben, die Stadien, da gibt es drei Sicherheitsgürtel drumrum und drei Ringe und drei Sicherheitskontrollen. So schlimm war es überhaupt nicht. Also es ist verstärkt worden im Vergleich zu den anderen Turnieren, kein Zweifel, aber auch jetzt nicht so übertrieben, dass man da stundenlang durch etliche Sicherheitskontrollen muss.
Das eigentlich Schlimme ist ja, dass wenn wir darüber reden, dass in Frankreich nichts passiert ist bisher, in anderen Orten der Welt ganz schreckliche Dinge passieren. Aber wenn man da ständig drüber nachdenkt, macht es einen auch kaputt. Wobei man die Berichterstattung hierzulande da noch mal hinterfragen könnte. Aber das wollen wir, also das muss dann vielleicht ein anderer Podcast machen, nicht der Rasenfunk. Hast du denn noch irgendwas mitbekommen von vereiteten oder vielleicht nicht berichteten Hooligan-Zusammenstößen? Man hat ja auch vor den deutschen Hooligans so einige Warnungen gehört. Und es hat ja zumindest auch bei Deutschland gegen Ukraine tatsächlich Schlägereien gegeben. Gab es da noch mal irgendwas oder ist das auch ein Thema, das weil nichts mehr vorgefallen ist, auch nicht mehr relevant war?
Ich denke auch, es ist wenig passiert in den letzten Tagen in der Richtung. Keine Stühle werden geschmissen, keine Auseinandersetzung mehr. Liegt natürlich auch daran, dass jetzt nur noch wenige Mannschaften im Turnier sind. Und ja, Island und Irland und so weiter, da weiß man ja, dass da bei den Fans nichts passiert. Ich hatte das auch gehört, dass sich deutsche Hooligans da verabredet haben, um sich irgendwo zu treffen, ist aber auch nicht so gewesen. Beim zweiten Mal Lille hing auch wieder die Reichskriegsflagge an der gleichen Brasserie wie beim ersten Spiel. Also eigentlich unfassbar. Ich habe mit der Polizei gesprochen, die sagten, wir wissen das, wir beobachten das. Aber solange da nichts passiert, machen wir nichts. Die fahren dann eine Deeskalation. Ich bin auch bei Twitter, als ich diesen Tweet rausgehauen habe, bin ich natürlich auch von irgendwelchen Schwachköpfen angeschrieben worden. Ja, aber die ist ja auch nicht verboten. Ja, de jure ist das dann so, vielleicht sieht die Polizei das auch so. Aber es ist natürlich schlimm, diese Verharmlosung und diese Leute, die sich dann stolz davor fotografieren lassen, die möchte auch niemand sehen. Aber es ist halt auch Tatsache, dass nichts passiert ist. Zumindest weiß ich von nichts. Ich hatte mit dem Korrespondenten auch telefoniert und dem gesagt, du, das ist da, weil ich ja dann auch zum Stadion musste. Und der sagte, ja, ich gucke mir das an, ob da was ist. Und da war halt dann nichts. Die sind irgendwann dann auch zum Stadion. Also ich weiß nicht, ob sie Karten haben, das kann ich nicht beurteilen. Ob die dann da geguckt haben oder zum Stadion gegangen sind, das weiß ich nicht. Aber ich habe nichts Nennenswertes in den vergangenen zwei, drei Wochen gehört oder mitgekriegt.
Was ja immer wieder thematisiert wird und unterschiedlich kritisch gesehen wird, je nachdem, auf welche Art Fan man trifft oder auf welche Haltung einfach dazu, sind die Fangesänge der deutschen Fans in den Stadien. Da haben wir unter anderem das inzwischen berühmt-berüchtigte Lied der Bösen Onkels. Zwischendurch wird die Nationalhymne gesungen und immer wieder Geisterntweets herum, die ich natürlich nicht verifizieren kann, weil ich nicht vor Ort bin, auch von fremdenfeindlichen und antisemitischen Gesängen. Hast du sowas auch wahrgenommen? Und was mich vor allem noch mehr interessieren würde dagegen tun, könnte ja tatsächlich nur eine organisierte Masse etwas. Und das wäre dann der Fan-Club Nationalmannschaft Powered by Coca-Cola. Da würde mich deine Einschätzung interessieren, hat der DFB, sieht er das überhaupt auch, diese Problematik? Oder findet man das vielleicht auch gar nicht problematisch?
Das muss ich dir ehrlich sagen, da bin ich überfragt, weil ich mir um diese Fan-Belange in der Beziehung noch gar nicht so gekümmert habe, weil das auch nicht zu meinem Aufgabengebiet gehört. Also klar, am Samstag gegen Italien gab es die Fangesänge Scheiß Italiener, das war für jeden zu hören. Ich muss dir ehrlich sagen, wahrscheinlich dieses Lied von den bösen Onkels ist wahrscheinlich das, wo ich mich die ganze Zeit frage, was singen die überhaupt? Deshalb gucke ich da immer, wenn das gesungen wird, gucke ich bei Twitter nach, ob irgendjemand da was zu schreibt. Und da ich aber niemals irgendwas gelesen habe, dachte ich, ja, das wird irgendwas sein, was dann Gott sei Dank aber harmlos ist. Da müsstest du mich jetzt echt aufklären, was das für ein Lied ist und was sie da singen, weil ich verstehe den Text nie.
Ohje, ich weiß es auch nicht. Ich glaube, es ist ein Lied. Ich glaube, es ist das Lied Mexico. Aber da könnte ich mich jetzt auch sehr in die Netze entsetzen. Ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt auch nicht genau. Ich weiß nur...
Ich kenne kein Lied von dem bösen Onkel, sondern ich will das auch nicht ändern. Von daher werde ich da auch gleich nicht googeln. Ich glaube, man muss doch nicht alles wissen.
Ja, es ist das Lied Mexico. Die Leute können es selber googeln. Ja, interessante Frage irgendwie. Eigentlich müsste man diese Frage mal an den DFB stellen, finde ich. Ob das überhaupt als Problem wahrgenommen wird?
Ja, das kann man machen. Ich meine, der Fanclub Nationalmannschaft ist ja organisiert. Die haben sicherlich einen Sprecher. Ich weiß nicht, ob das über die Medienabteilung des DFB geht. Also ich kann das morgen beim Training gerne mal fragen, wer der Ansprechpartner ist, wen man da fragen kann. Und wenn das dann jemand machen möchte, dann kannst du ja mal anrufen oder anmailen.
Marcus, da hast du mir gerade eine Tür geöffnet, durch die ich sehr gerne gehe. Wenn du das machen könntest, sehr nett, dann gucken wir mal. Das werde ich sehr gerne tun, dann gucken wir mal. Wahrscheinlich wird es im Rahmen der EM nicht mehr klappen, aber kann man ja auch mal so einfach diskutieren, denn es interessiert mich wirklich, wie man dem gegenübersteht. Und dann gibt es noch ein anderes Thema, was im Vorfeld der EM einmal kurz aufploppt und dann während EM, und zwar den ganzen Themenbereich Doping und dann im Zuge der EM auch Schmerzmitteleinsatz. Doping wurde vor allem deshalb relevant, weil es ein höchst interessantes Urteil gab. Die Dopingproben vom Dopingarzt Fuentes, auch die Fußballerproben, die irgendwie mysteriöserweise immer aus seinem Prozess rausgehalten wurden, die dürfen jetzt geöffnet werden, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe. Auch dazu wird es bestimmt nochmal was im Rasenfunk geben, wo wir da ausführlicher drauf eingehen. Das war ganz kurz vor Beginn der EM, deswegen ging das ein bisschen unter. Und dann gab es während der Europamasterschaft eine Recherche des Recherchenetwerks Korrektiv, die wir auch mal mit Jonathan Sachse beim Tribünengespräch zu Fußballdoping zu Gast hatten. Wer sich für den Themenkomplex interessiert, da gibt es vier hoffentlich informative Stunden dazu. Da müsst ihr mal nach dem Tribünengespräch zu Fußballdoping suchen. Die haben im Müll von mehreren Teams gewühlt, buchstäblich. Sind nicht bei allen an die Müllammer rangekommen, unter anderem bei der deutschen Nationalmannschaft, aber haben hohe Dosen von Schmerzmitteln gefunden, im ukrainischen Müll vor allem, und vor allem relevant in Spritzenform, was man eigentlich aus verschiedenen Nebenwirkungsgründen gar nicht mehr so macht und was zumindest fragwürdig ist. Jetzt sind da keine verbotenen Substanzen mit dabei gewesen, aber ich finde das Thema Schmerzmittel so interessant. Du als erfahrener Hase, sag mir mal, wie sollte ich denn, als noch nicht so erfahrener Hase, in meiner Berichterstattung damit umgehen? Es gibt die Realität, Schmerzmittel gehören zum Alltag eines Fußballprofis dazu und gleichzeitig gehört es auch zur Berichterstattungsmentalität oder Realität, dass ich zum Beispiel auch ich hier im Rasenfunk, Bastian Schweinsteiger, dafür feiere, wenn er sich durchs WM-Finale 2014 schleppt. Oder sollte er jetzt zum Beispiel doch auflaufen? Oder letztlich habe ich ihn auch dafür gefeiert, vorhin erst vor ein paar Minuten, dass er gegen Italien trotz Verletzung in der ersten Aktion weitergespielt hat. Man will nicht immer der Miesmacher sein, der sagt, ja, aber es könnte ja auch Schmerzmittelmissbrauch sein oder im schlimmsten Fall sogar Doping. Aber auf der anderen Seite muss man es ja doch auch immer mal wieder thematisieren. Denn der Fußball geht da schon sehr gerne drüber weg über dieses Thema, oder?
Ich finde aber, das ist einer der Bereiche, wo man genauso wie Hooligans, rechtsradikale Unterwanderungen im Fußball, das sind Bereiche, wo man sich raushalten soll, wenn man nicht über das Wissen verfügt, um seriös und fundiert darüber zu berichten. Und das Wissen müsste ich mir aneignen, habe ich nicht. Bei Schmerzmitteln auch nicht. Und das ist ein Thema, da müssen wirklich Experten ran, wie von dir angesprochenen gerade. Ich habe es auch mit Interesse gelesen. Natürlich ist Schmerzmittel ein großes Thema im Leistungssport und hundertprozentig auch im Fußball. Einerseits muss man natürlich sagen, muss jeder selber wissen, was er seinem Körper zumutet. Beziehungsweise die Ärzte müssen wissen, was sie den Körpern ihrer Klienten zumuten oder ihrer Patienten in dem Fall. Das ist furchtbar viel Grauzone. Jeder, denke ich, reagierte auch anders. Ich kann jetzt sagen, ich habe ein sehr interessantes Sportgespräch. Ich habe mal im Deutschlandfunk gehört, das war vor der Handball-EM. Mit Oliver Roggisch müsste, da das ein Jahr zur Verfügung steht, auch noch in der Mediathek zu holen sein.
Ich werde es raussuchen.
Es war äußerst interessant, kurz und knapp gesagt. Er sagte, es war mal ein Riesenproblem bei den Handballern. Also bis über die Grenze sei inzwischen viel besser geworden. Ich kenne für den Fußballer keine vergleichbaren Aussagen. Zumindest während dieser EM sehe ich keine Möglichkeit, mit einem Verantwortlichen des DFB darüber zu sprechen. Die Gelegenheit wird sich nicht ergeben, selbst auf Anfrage. Das kann man vergessen, auch jetzt angesichts der knappen Zeit. Donnerstag ist das Halbfinale, Sonntag eventuell Finale. Ich finde es ein super interessantes Thema und lese es gerne nach, bei den Menschen, die da Ahnung von haben. Aber ich sage für mich, ich habe nicht die Ahnung davon, um da seriös darüber zu berichten und das einfach mal so im Halbsatz anzudeuten, wenn der Schweinsteiger Donnerstag spielen sollte, nach dem Motto, man möchte ja nicht wissen, wie der jetzt fitgespritzt wurde oder so.
Ja, okay, da gebe ich dir schon recht. Aber auf der anderen Seite, wenn sich nur die absoluten Experten zu allem äußern, dann werden zum einen ganz, ganz viele Leute gar nichts mehr sagen. Bei manchen vielleicht gar nicht mehr so unangenehm. Aber was ich ganz ernsthaft meine, das kann ja auch nicht die Lösung sein, dass man letztlich ja dann letztlich geht man dann doch diese Schweigetaktik ein, die unter anderem ja auch der DFB fährt. Wenn du mir sagst, man bekommt dazu auch gar keine Aussage, wo ich jetzt mal unterstellen würde, die Hypothese, eigentlich müsste man, wenn man dazu, also wenn man da eine absolut reine Weste hat, kann man da doch eigentlich auch super drüber reden. Ich will jetzt nicht unterstellen, dass es eine unreine Weste gibt, aber man macht doch dann diese Schweigetaktik mit.
Ja, das ist, also nicht falsch verstehen. Das hat jetzt nichts mit dem Thema zu tun. Das ist vielleicht grundsätzlich. Also ich habe zumindest auch noch nichts gelesen. Ich habe mit dem Psychologen Herrmann noch kein Interview gelesen. Oder selbst sowas Banales wie der Koch. Sowas wurde ja auch immer gerne genommen, Interviews mit dem Koch. Was kriegen die Spieler denn da zu essen, habe ich auch noch nicht gesehen. Ich habe jetzt nicht nachgefragt und kann es nicht hundertprozentig sagen. Aber ich glaube, aus dem Stab rund um, es wird ja gerne das Team hinter dem Team genannt oder so, äußert sich während der Mannschaft noch keiner. Genau, hat sich noch keiner geäußert. Und das wird in den letzten Tagen sicherlich nicht anders werden. Also nichts damit zu tun, dass die zu bestimmten sensiblen oder heiklen Themen nichts sagen wollen, sondern das gilt grundsätzlich. Aber das kann man. Und eins auch noch, Experte meine ich jetzt nicht, dass man Mediziner sein muss, um sich damit zu beschäftigen, aber man muss halt so tief drinstecken, dass man mit den Leuten zumindest mal inoffiziell gesprochen hat und dass man weiß, was abgeht, dass man mit Ex-Profis vielleicht mal gesprochen hat. Dass man eine Grundlage eines Wissens hat, nur zu sagen, dass Schmerzmittel verwandt werden, und das ist mir halt zu wenig. Und da würden wir dann wünschen, dass da Leute drangehen, die sich da eingehen mit beschäftigen. Und da sind der Jonathan Sachse und der Daniel Drepper sicherlich absolut geeignet. Und wenn die was darüber schreiben, dann lese ich das auch gerne. Und dann weiß ich auch, dass das fundiert ist.
Also, sehr wichtige Einschränkungen erst mal mit dem DFB. Da hast du natürlich vollkommen recht. Wenn die sich generell gar nicht äußern, dann muss ich da auch die halbgemachte Unterstellung definitiv auch zurücknehmen. Trotzdem frage ich mich manchmal, ich muss ja auch nicht immer gleich unterstellen, oder wurde jetzt etwas getan, was vielleicht nicht unbedingt illegal ist, aber nicht im medizinischen Sinne ratsam. Aber könnte man nicht zum Beispiel auch einfach versuchen, und damit meine ich mich selbst auch mit am meisten, auch so Leistungen, die über die Grenzen der körperlichen Belastung fast hinausgehen, bei Sportler vielleicht auch nicht mehr so abzufeiern. Ich habe so den Eindruck, man bedient da auch total gerne. Das war natürlich ikonisch, wie Bastian Schweinsteiger dann sogar irgendwann bluten nach dem 120. Faul der Argentinier an ihm, am Spielfeldrand lag und dann Kevin Großkreutz nicht eingewechselt wurde, weil er gesagt hat, nee, ich gehe jetzt da rein und mache das fertig. Das war natürlich ein tolles Bild und auch eine tolle Geschichte. Aber vielleicht sollte man solche Geschichten dann auch gar nicht mehr mit so einem Werf dann erzählen. Ich weiß es nicht, ich bin da so ein bisschen hilflos, ehrlich gesagt.
Diese Hilflosigkeit ist natürlich dadurch gegeben, dass wir über Dinge sprechen, die nicht verboten sind. Sie stehen nicht auf der Dopingliste. Und deshalb dreht man sich da im Kreis, denke ich auch. Das ist ein Teil der Berichterstattung, die natürlich auch immer darauf gerichtet sein muss, dass es die Leute interessiert. Und wenn du so ein Argument, das mögen Leute für schwach halten, aber es ist nun mal ein richtiges, die Sachen sind nicht verboten, warum sollte man dann darüber diskutieren? Das sind die Argumente der Leute, sind für mich auch verständlich. Man könnte sicherlich ausführlich darüber sprechen. Und es gibt ja auch sicherlich Berichte und Texte darüber. Das hat man ja jetzt auch gesehen. Der Ansatz der Recherche, für den finde ich ja schon sehr interessant, da im Müll zu wühlen.
Gelernt bei der Tour de France.
Und das ist richtig, ja. Das wird ja vielleicht auch uns in den nächsten Wochen dann noch häufiger begegnen, wieder das Müll buchen. Aber Tour de France, vielleicht der Kollege Michael Ostermann, der jetzt für die Sportschau gerade bei der Tour de France ist, das kann sein, dass der sich da viel besser auskenn, als ich, weil du im Radsport, selbst wenn vielen Fahrern das natürlich auch auf den Geist ging, dass sie dauernd auf Doping gesprochen haben, aber die Zugänge zu den Fahrern und die mal zur Seite zu nehmen und mit denen mal ein inoffizielles Gespräch zu führen, die sind immer noch deutlich besser als bei den Fußballern. Der könnte dir sicherlich wesentlich mehr über Schmerzmittel im Radsport und dann auch Leistungssport erzählen, aber ob der beim Fußball so weiß. Ich kenne jetzt keinen, der mal recherchiert hat, außer jetzt den, der genannten.
Es ist irgendwie schwierig, ich denke da auch schon länger drüber nach. Das Problem ist eben auch, dass Körperlichkeit und über die Grenzen zu gehen und zu kämpfen, dass das ein wesentliches Element des Sports generell ist. Deswegen ist es dann auch logisch, dass man es feiert, wenn jemand den Schmerz besiegt. Man merkt das ja an sich selbst, wenn man selbst Sport betreibt. Das ist ja dieser ganz normale Rhythmus. Der Körper sagt, jetzt fängt es an weh zu tun, und dann sagt der Kopf, ja geil, jetzt geht es los, jetzt gehe ich über eine Grenze drüber. Deswegen gehört das ja auch dazu. Wie gesagt, ich bin da auch, wahrscheinlich bin ich da auch deswegen so hilflos, weil ich auch ein wahnsinniger NFL-Fan bin, obwohl ich weiß, was da passiert bei denen. Da geht es ja noch ganz anders ab. Ja, schwieriges Thema. Wir werden es auch heute wahrscheinlich nicht gelöst bekommen, Marcus, aber ich finde es mal ganz interessant, da deine Einschätzung zuzuhören. Vielen Dank dafür. So, wie machen wir jetzt da jetzt den Deckel drauf? Siehste, Miesmacher-Thema. Ich weiß es nicht.
Jetzt, die wieder zum Fußball zu kommen, ist in der Tat echt schwierig.
Wir müssen einfach aufhören wahrscheinlich. Oder hast du noch einen Schwank aus Evian zu erzählen? Es gab einen Autokorso, habe ich jetzt gelesen, und ich konnte es nicht glauben.
Das war tatsächlich gut. Ich hatte eigentlich gestern Abend vor, mir das Spiel in Ruhe hier auf dem Hotelzimmer anzugucken. Dann haben mich Kollegen doch überredet, hier ganz in die Nähe, in so ein Kneipe zu gehen. Und wir haben uns schon gewundert, wie voll die war. Wir hatten da schon mal ein Spiel geguckt, auch ein Spiel Frankreichs. Da waren vielleicht ein Viertel und gestern waren es sehr voll. Es waren sehr viele im französischen Trikot. Es war sehr laut bei der Nationalhymne und es war auch sehr angenehm. Also wir haben sehr viel auch mit denen gesprochen. Es war erstmals zu merken, dass hier in Frankreich eine Europameisterschaft ist. Und Autokorso war dann tatsächlich –Autokorso ist vielleicht übertrieben, weil so viele Menschen hier nicht wohnen –aber alle, die mit dem Auto durchs Dorf gefahren sind oder durch die Stadt, die haben auch kräftig auf die Hupe gedrückt. Und das dauerte ziemlich lange. Und was man auch deutlich sagen muss, die Zahl der Fenster, aus denen jetzt französische Flaggen hängen, hat deutlich zugenommen jetzt in der KU-Phase.
Ja, das ist doch sehr interessant zu hören, dass da jetzt die Euphorie sich durchsetzt. Übrigens, kleiner Lesetipp für die Hörer. Und falls du, wahrscheinlich hattest du noch nicht die Zeit dafür, auch für dich. Frederic Ballin hat, der Ed Frewell auf Twitter hat einen Essay geschrieben, Sedan schweigt, gibt es als E-Book für, ich glaube, drei Euro oder sowas, wo er die kulturellen, soziologischen und gesellschaftlichen Hintergründe der Entwicklung in Frankreich von 1998 an bis eben jetzt in die Gegenwart nach erzählt, eben ausgehend davon, dass damals die Nationalmannschaft von Sedan 1998 als geglücktes Beispiel für geglückte Integration gefeiert wurde. Und wir alle wissen, wie es sich in Frankreich, und ja nicht nur da, auch in Deutschland, danach entwickelt hat, mit brennenden Autos in den Bordeliers und bis hin jetzt zu offenem Rassismus und merkwürdigen Diskussionen im ganzen Land. Sehr, sehr lesenswert und interessant. Kann ich echt empfehlen. Werde ich definitiv verlinken. Das wird jetzt mal eine Folge, bei der ich mal wieder Show Notes machen muss, die den Namen verdient haben. Das habe ich mir beim Kurzpass bisher immer gespart. Markus, ich danke dir sehr, sehr. Das war echt mal interessant und ein bisschen eine andere Kurzpass-Folge. Vielen Dank, dass du dir dafür Zeit genommen hast. Und auch vielen Dank an die Hörer, die bis hierhin gehört haben. Folgt Markus bei Twitter. Er heißt dort etartus69. Und wir Hübschen hören uns wieder morgen, wenn es den nächsten Kurzpass gibt. Und dann reden wir natürlich über das erste Halbfinale, Waze gegen Portugal. Und dann geht es ja auch weiter mit dem nächsten Halbfinale, Deutschland gegen Frankreich. Und meine Güte, dann wartet ein Finale auf uns. Bis dahin wünsche ich euch eine gute Zeit. Macht's gut, ciao.